hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to bendy and the dark
Revival we're in the middle of a mystery
we don't know well I forgot about you
but I don't need to worry about you
we're in the middle of a mystery we
don't know who our papa is and isn't
that so sad were we made out of the ink
are we a real human
are we a real human being we're not oh
no
we're fine oh can I please I was through
the Gap I was through the gap for
Shirley's
where am I
where am I where am I where am I where
am I I see I see somehow I made it up
here and I don't know how
was I supposed to get up here I guess
this is where you would have gone if you
would have like
zipped your way over but
what
oh I made it
okay apparently it's the death skip I I
I don't know if I was I might have
broken the game did I break the game I
feel like I might have broken the game
oh no
hello the keepers have taken my friend
locked him away like some animal just
because he's big and strong but they
don't need to fear Him no if they just
make sure to feed him on time Big Steve
won't even hurt a fly he loves the food
from the little Devil Lounge best if
only someone would take the long road
back through the sewers climb up the
Elevator Shaft and seek out his favorite
thumping delicacy then they would see
how harmless he really is
are you telling me to take the long road
back through the sewers climb up the
Elevator Shaft and seek out his favorite
thumping delicacy because I'm not gonna
do that I don't care how cool this
person is I'm not gonna do that why
would anybody do that that's so out of
the way just to see how harmless someone
that probably is gonna kill me is
yeah whatever oh I could have flowed at
any moment to run away there
right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a problem
great
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
what
am I about to see how harmless someone
is Hey listen pal
how are you doing how are you doing
ah am I gonna have to take the long road
back hey what's up buddy are you
harmless
hi what's up
hello
you uh you mind if I all right well
I know what I'm being stared at
menacingly in silence
buy someone with a mouth that is way too
horrifying for my taste
good okay I don't even know how I got up
here
what's this girl oh yes made it
hello
26 comes before 44.
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my God
why would you do that why would you do
that just to mix things up
just to get a little ha ha in here
is that all you wanted
you're an a-hole
and I don't like you good thing my flow
recharges so quickly is there anything
out there worth getting why am I up here
at all I don't even know
ah I'm up here now shut up and screw you
huh
that really got me that quite got me so
how do I get over to the Sewer am I
supposed to do that do I need to go back
all the way to the long road because I
just came from the sewer up the Elevator
Shaft oh
do I I'm kind of curious about this this
might be an episode entirely dedicated
to a side mission but
you don't hear a thing Wham oh
didn't hear a thing
uh good thing I'm so stealthy
yeah nice
oh
wait a minute just not nice where am I
I'm not exactly as far as I thought I
would be
oh I could use a card yeah why not
anybody got any food here any fud
thank you
fud
fod
a dude
this is a kitchen why is there no fud
you're really gonna make me buy it
really gonna make me buy the food fine
okay I'm out of here no I'm out here you
can't catch me
you can't catch me wait a minute
I didn't need any well you missed me I'm
crouching would be great it doesn't want
to crouch sometimes it just doesn't want
to crouch all right so I don't know why
but I'm compelled to see if this is a
real thing so I'm gonna go back until I
find a sewer and then I'm going to go
forward in time
and through the other thing because this
might be a wild goose chase this might
be but at the same time
I'm a sucker for a side quest I am just
a sucker for a side quest it says long
road back to the Sewer up an elevator to
little Devil's Diner to get the favorite
snack and it's letting me go back
I am able to go back so I will be back
in a bit if this is a reality maybe also
I just remembered wow Audrey told me to
stay right there or Alice or whoever it
was told me to stay there and not move
and man I moved so much and I still
haven't heard a peep
from them
why
I've moved so hard you told me to not
move right here and I move so movely I
moved so much I feel like I've left
alone
I'm all alone how am I gonna get up an
elevator oh you shut up
shut up don't
how am I gonna get up An Elevator Shaft
how does anybody get up an elevator for
that I'm oh oh oh
I see
I can totally do that
ah there we go
oh
no way
oh my God
this side quest had better be the most
incredible worth it thing in the history
of any side quest ever wow
[Applause]
whoa who was with the eye
okay
the machine must endure she must it
hello what
[Music]
was that supposed to ding I think it was
supposed to ding I think the programmers
forgot to put a ding in there dingy Ling
so
that still doesn't get me back up to the
diner
I could technically maybe get up on that
one oh
oh yes I am
yes I am and good thing I spent all my
points on charging that up okay I'm back
hey what's up bars oh man anybody seen a
diner here anybody anybody seen a side
quest is worth going to a diner for
anybody
oh just me all right okay well
I'm oh where where where where where
where where where where where where
where where where
please be a barrel like an idea oh frick
oh frick oh frick
[Music]
really in my grundle you're really gonna
where are you gonna put my auto save
because I haven't actually done anything
if you put me back I swear to God if you
put me back I swear to God if you put me
back I swear to God if you put me
foreign
God damn it why would it do that
skipping hi what's up pal imma get you
something don't worry your Gob is gonna
be stuffed stuffed to the brim to the
gills I'll be back all right I'm back
here now I'll look for a hiding hole
first where's a hidey hole there's a
hidey hole okay we've identified the
hidey hole so if I just need if I get in
trouble I go to that hidey hole
oh there's another one that was right
where I was God if I'd have just turned
around I would have been 100 fine
I'm do not turn me around like that ever
again
hey hey what are you doing what are you
doing
stop
thank you uh where is
I don't even know where that would be
where where would this be it's so far
the little Devil's Diner isn't that way
back in like the very beginning
am I crazy
uh-huh
it is it is because this
is how you get back in the beginning
this is how you get back to the
beginning right of course it is
Whoa stop doing that God with the
turning me around
foreign
just being angry
where am I
I had oh I didn't have a card because I
didn't change it out because I died last
time that's right and wouldn't you know
it we're all the way back here
and it's uh the long way back to the
little devil Diner right here
wow little devil la
well that's unfortunate there I know one
of these is a high deal yes
oh you're not gonna give me this time
you're not gonna give me this time
not this time
not this time okay
so I'm here right
whoa tab that's the weird button for
that to be that okay uh uh he loves food
from the little Devil Lounge
so is there a specific food is there
like any food if I go in here could I
not go in here before maybe
battery it's awfully gurgly in here
special food
oh
oh
oh
all right on the wall I'm gonna say
we're gonna save so I don't die man all
right I'm going back baby but first i'm
gonna eat some food for me too okay I'm
good here we go
you
mean
[Music]
oh my God why why is that a thing that
you do
oh no not now wait but no wait but no
but how am I
there's no hiding space it's so good
that I saved you may not have seen it it
might not have been put in but I saved
no I'm not going to load my auto save
because I saved before that just as I
was coming out of the sewers after I'd
done all that because I wasn't going to
be caught with my pants down again and
it really wanted to catch me with my
pants down and I wasn't gonna let it
so yes I'm right here which is not far
from where I just died and I'm sure
that if I were to look now right if I
was a look and I would see like oh wow
there's that's a lot of food I would see
like oh there's a hiding space somewhere
won't give me a second time idiot
no actually I don't see any hiding
spaces actually I see no hiding spaces
which is really reassuring
great there was none there was none
there was none all right I'm back oh man
that was great I'm glad I did that also
it's kind of impressive that I can go
all the way back to the beginning
but that's besides the point I'm angry
I'm grumpy that I had to do that and I
did it of my own volition and no one
made me do it and I just did it because
I I for some reason saw a challenge and
I couldn't back down from The Challenge
and so I ended up doing the challenge
hi what's up
oh well that's not good missed me
stupid
so dumb oh maybe not dumb maybe dumb
maybe super dumb
all right I did it I got your food
You're Gonna Love This apparently there
you go
you know I guess I could have just asked
him to go over to the other side but
whatever
I feel like that would just be a one
bite kind of thing for you but who am I
to judge what does this do
hole
I guess that's in case you
really it's a safe as a safe here
some money
can't even grab it there's a money up
box
what is this I ate a slab of meat
oh a key okay
I just got a gent card
can I use it I can't
I can't even
I
I do uh I I have a I have a card
and I
approxy schematicus
at least I got a schematic
I'm really hoping that schematic is the
greatest schematic that anybody's ever
seen in the history of forever because
it it'd have to be it would it would
have to be the most incredible schematic
that any human ink monster anything
creature of the deep of the Damned it
would have to be the most
outlandishly
unbelievable thing I hope it's like
the Dead Space 2 foam finger gun bang
bang
incredible weapon incredible really
I oh
uh-huh
[Music]
at least
never quite the same uh-huh I caught up
in the door for you I do know how I
really do
q that was like but this maybe play a
game oh I love to play games I like hide
and seek best find me and I'll open the
door for you I I promise look away while
I hide and no thinking
is Heidi in this room is it just in this
room
idru
you in this room
are you in this
Heidi are you in the room
are you outside of the room
are you in the room or out of the room I
are you in room out of room
you in the room
room room room
[Music]
I don't want to play this game
I don't want to play this game
not this game in like this game bendy I
want to play but I don't want to play
the hide and seek game I didn't sign up
for hide and seek ID
her name is Heidi I see
that makes sense oh yeah I didn't get
any of this because I died
you all right
oh don't get me don't do it don't Hi D I
don't Heidi
oh
man you look pissed
all right fine so am I supposed to check
like these hiding spots
no
I
find the giggling lost one so you're
giggling somewhere
how far back are you
I thought I heard something
oh yeah let's see what this upgrade
could be
stun coil stun mod double charged gent
pipe will stun Keepers on impact I guess
that's pretty good if only I had more of
those I have exactly as of everything
else but not that
where
what
has that always been there was that just
sitting there did I miss that
man I don't even know
I don't know what this episode is guys I
don't know what this episode is I have
no idea
but I slugged down some thick ink and I
feel good she must have been back in the
other area there's no way that it would
have made me go out right there's no way
the clue is that there's giggling but
there were really no parameters of where
it could be
but it's fine
oh
where are you at
where'd you go wait what the hell why is
this restocked
wait a minute
pray tell what
I heard giggling
I heard it
another toolkit I heard giggling
what's going on
what's the deal
oh you you you I'm gonna whack you right
in your head
You Found Me Oh this is so exciting
yeah now can you open that door for me
I think you'll find it's open now oh oh
and also let me give you something
something special
small reminder about getting together
what did you just do to me
whoa what
[Applause]
you just gave me the ability
fast travel
for example just for example all the way
back to the diner you gave me the power
to do that
now
I'm much better
I feel better
I feel sane
I feel like myself I don't know exactly
how I'm supposed to do that
nope what what was the button you said
there might have been a button was it oh
you go up to this thing ah foreign
where am I going
oh
interesting
um but I don't wanna I wanna I don't I
don't wanna go I want to go I want to go
that's very handy but at the same time I
wanna I don't want to go there just yet
so I wanna I wanna progress forward I've
already done that thing weirdly enough
you might not be like wow man you
wouldn't have walked all the way back
there well I did
and uh I'm also very curious about why
this was it's restocked again
how
do you keep restocking yourself
can I just Farm up the thing I needs for
the the the things eyes needs for the
umiza
the um is that why uh every time I think
I've looted a place before I come back
and be like oh I must be dumb I forgot
something I wasn't dumb it just
it responds okay whatever
hey now finally halfway through this
episode I can progress forward
oh it's open
well
what are you are there Inky bacteria
what could possibly be decontaminated
are there diseases in here
did he draw up diseases
oh
excuse me
sir
can you help me
you must be
really lost
just looking for answers
about the keepers
Wilson the cycle anything could help
Audrey
what's yours
[Music]
my name is Henry
[Music]
prisoner long
and the keepers thank you
they lock you away
forever
still it's giving me time to think
things like
if you haven't eaten in years
you might not be human
why would you be a threat to them
[Music]
Once Upon a
upon a completely new
obviously Wilson and the keepers don't
want
them how did you do it reset the cycle
turns out the ink demon himself
this world is his
and he must obey his voice
for now at least
if you can get him to look at something
very specific he will reset every
where what is it
it's just
able to put the words at the end I can
see
every day
I'll see if I can break in and steal it
maybe if I reset the cycle we could make
things better for everyone here
and what about you
[Music]
good luck
Audrey if you need
me you know where to find me thanks so
that's the person from the first game
well did you hear that because I sure
didn't no I definitely didn't nope
didn't hear nothing about that what
well I guess we're not going to worry
about it because it's not worth
something worth Where Are You Worry
worrying about
nope
not I
hello
let me get
well
interesting how are you doing God
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] wait uh I don't really
have a hidey hole I'm gonna assume this
little straddling crouchy spot is
definitely gonna hide me
foreign
the ground to grab me in the taint
um see the problem with that was I don't
remember I don't know when it would have
Auto saved and I haven't manually saved
in a bit so if you
I'm hoping it did it
foreign
[Music]
nightmare creature big on
oh
all right
well I feel better does everyone feel
bad wreck you freaking
man this episode I don't know what's
going on with this episode but it's not
going my way
oh I could tell you that much
I can't tell you much else but I can
tell you that much hey I remember that
ax and that thing I remember that is
from the first d game interesting
very interesting security lock
sure
I happen to slam down every single thing
I see so why not that
food I don't need food subject nine to
eight interesting
hello
are you worthy to walk with angels
I don't know am I you tell me huh
is there any more of those viewports
any more of the vuperts
and then else I should know about
oh wait here we go
there's one over here
hello
hey I use Dune
you uh
you enjoying yourself
okey-dokey then well you're real dreary
company
so I'm not going to worry about you too
much unless you come after me huh
this way
let these you battery nope
I imagine there was a lot more whoa okay
we're invisible
there was a lot more mechanics to do
with the battery
like progressing and keeping doors open
and whatnot and boozy woods and Woody
who's it's there's always hope
[Music]
when you just so happen to stumble upon
a giant head that's looking at you still
so it's indicative that it's still alive
and you know it shows a nightmare
existence beyond our understanding and
comprehension of reality
milk
milk I don't know why I'm doing this for
milk actually I know exactly what I'm
doing this from this from yeah I thought
my neck just snapped in half
uh yeah an alarm clock to count
depression hours of the day I didn't say
that sentence right there's not much
time so every second together is special
Buenas honest a carton of milk for
growing up strong and healthy adds some
chocolate for a snack enjoyed by both
young and old what is this just selling
me on milk what's the what's the deal
what's the dealio
what's the deal
[Music]
what do I do whoa
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh no
don't look behind you
whatever you do don't turn around
I told you not today do that but you did
it anyway so whatever
good
great
huh
a savior comes at last
Wilson oh hey
you're still
the keepers can be relentless to
strangers
but there's nothing to fear as long as
I'm with you you're safe now
you brought me here turned me into this
this thing this doesn't make sense I've
never done anything to you open your
eyes and look around
none of this makes sense
drawn walls
nightmarish creatures an ancient Studio
that died out almost 30 years ago
it's all fiction utter nonsense
and yet
in here it exists it's breathes it
flourishes
Guided by its Master's pin
the foundation for a new reality I can
bleed
and just think of it
anything we create in here we can
release him out there
like first
this world must be controlled
made safe
these
these angels and demons
are they really live
or are they just
stains
old mistakes ready to be cleansed away
for newer greater things
what do you want from me
I
need your help
to to save my father's life
this is our star we'll talk more once
we're safely inside
[Music]
um
questions
why are you get off who do you think you
are who do you think I am all right I'm
gonna stand up now
I don't have any more questions I really
am confused about everything and also
you are way too creepy sounding for your
own good because it makes you not
actually that creepy the one I think
that's my thing
never mind it's not I have two eyes I'm
better than you shut up
man you I'll take this
uh-huh yeah it's been
what
hello
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean abilities are disabled you
disabled my abilities
you my abilities hello
um
well that's a little rude I just gave
you a smooch but I guess kissing someone
out of the blue like that does probably
mode a little disgusting so I apologize
that's my fault I apologize I apologize
to you
awesome right
I know I was supposed to stay close but
I I've lost him already old track 77 is
a quiet place these days ever since that
terrible crash a few years back people
don't like to hang around too many
strange things keep happening on this
platform last week one of the realmen
told me they hadn't had reports some
train going through that wasn't on
schedule there were figures standing in
the cars staring through the windows but
it never stopped to let anyone off just
kept going straight through some say it
was the Silver Lane Express the train
crashed
all right did someone pen that into this
place did someone write that in is that
the story that someone wrote Because
that's sad and spooky
good morning
why morning why so much moaning always
always with the shmonen where did you go
Wilson
how how did I lose you uh
[Music]
carry on
good job
oh yeah
yep oh hi
I didn't exactly stay close
to spread evil
who are you to say was evil
[Music]
nothing nothing
almost there just a quick stop will take
but a moment
uh-huh checkpoint what do you mean let's
stop
Wilson
no I
said
I don't think I want to I don't really
want to is that a gun holy crap give me
the gun
okay but what if I don't
what if I don't I got a bad feeling
about this all right
the subject will submit ow
L
uh-huh
well fine
I do like the gun though the gun is
pretty dope
who needs it it's a pipe
okay thank you
hmm I will how'd you get there oh
nullify the ink Demon's Powers so he
cannot pass them I wish I could say I
invented them but it seems our friends
at the Gent Corporation had a demon
problem of their own long ago oh we all
have our demon
[Music]
yeah
I hate you I hate you I hate you
I hate you who's I hate them
oh my dear if you're an excuse I'm not
gonna
we'll talk later I promise
besides you must be very tired the quick
rest will do you good Betty will show
you to your room I don't want she's my
housekeeper no
other things I don't want to know never
actually killed the ink demon did you no
he's too powerful to destroy so we
sealed him away trapped him in a
different form one that was smaller
harmless bendy it was a fitting prison
although he seems to have found a way to
free himself
but enough talk
deal with that
soon enough
nice fresh blankets all laid out for you
you'll be dreaming in no time wait
Wilson
one more thing
if you needed my help why didn't you
just ask
[Music]
yeah
come along probably this way now
with the same way that Wilson went I
feel like maybe it should have been the
other you sure you sure
it's so exciting finally having you with
us now
we're currently standing in the South
Wing Wilson's laboratory is downstairs
and then there's the north wing
uh-huh
uh-huh
what is down here
who's with this who's with the door
what's with that Betty who's over there
oh push smash oh stab
don't do that ever
don't
don't
a while ago and ever since we've had to
keep the north Wing locked up tight I'm
afraid it's fallen into ruins by now
only Keepers go there these days and
they'll tear you apart limb from Lim if
Wilson's with you
mind your distance and you'll be just
fine
uh
-hun-up
[Music]
is this my room
almost everyone here either can't speak
or they're completely mad
I wonder why that would be why would
that be
have you ever thought about that
yourself
hmm you should see where I sleep
but this room oh just perfect I saw to
every detail that is clean that bathroom
is on the left sorry about the stains I
did try my best to get them out
is this Gonna Stand
in the sleeping drafts old cocoa powder
count and Gilson what's this they're
exactly three sips what's a sip
the mug in the maiden
sure is Lovelier
no bad vibes
can't even get in the bathroom no bad
vibes
zero bad vibes here
well you just stared
do you have any questions how do I get
out of here is it always night here
it's always dark if that's what you mean
for as long as I can remember
are you very old no as far as I
understand it I'm something quite new
although
I didn't turn out the way I was supposed
to one in a long line of failed
experiments
Wilson will keep trying I don't want why
do you trust Wilson
the realm of the ink demon
Shadow hangs over us all I don't trust
anyone
but Wilson takes care of me keeps me
safe
he once said I remind him of something
he called his
mother tell me is that a good thing
where you two are from
I'm not sure yeah I'm not sure either I
don't think I ever had one
well
no matter
so get nice and comfy and relax
I left something on the table that might
just help you nod off
it's my own recipe works very fast
just follow the instructions
carefully
very carefully of course thanks birdie
if you need anything else I'll come
straight away I'm always up okay
yeah all right I guess I might as well
asleep
what's a Gilson I don't know what is a
Gilson got a bad guy
oh my God
have I got a Gilson in there
go to Gilson down there
I'm pooping
feels like a horror game
I mean I guess technically it's kind of
horror game
not gonna get me Freddy I'm not gonna
give me Five Nights at Freddy's toilet
not gonna get me
got five nights in the
Five Nights at Freddy's bathroom
all right well
hey what you doing there
well
too bad about those stains huh
go bad about them stains what about
those things
well I don't know where Gilson is Gilson
Gilson
do I gotta go out for some Gilson
hey buddy you got Gilson Maddie
hello
[Music]
revealing its mini possibilities
but I can accomplish using its power
is beyond any measure
life and death can become a thing of the
past
poverty and hunger a distance memory I
can remake the world a new
[Music]
does the world deserve such a gift
for now I have bigger matches at hand a
man in a black coat came out
came as said he was from the Gent
Corporation
fortunately the receptionist knew
nothing
he left
quite later I found his name on the sign
in form
Alan Gray
how is anybody from the Gent Corporation
here I have so many questions but what I
don't have is time thank you everybody
so much for watching I promise the next
episode is going to be a lot more
productive and a lot less of me
screaming in Rage
maybe we'll see
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]